Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why the
mass avoidance of some business is called
boycotting.
This term was named after a nineteenth century
Englishman, Captain Charles C. Boycott (who
originally had the surname “Boycatt,”
but the family changed the spelling when he
was nine years old).
If you guessed that at a certain point Captain
Boycott became quite unpopular with the masses,
you’re correct.
Shortly before Boycott would find himself
boycotted, the situation in Ireland was that
just 0.2% of the population owned almost every
square inch of land in Ireland.
Most of the owners of the land also didn’t
live in Ireland but simply rented their land
out to tenant farmers, generally on one-year
leases.
In the mid-nineteenth century, many of these
tenant farmers banded together with three
goals: “Fair Rent, Fixity of Tenure, and
Free Sale”.
One particular organization that emerged in
the 1870s pushing these “Three F’s,”
among other things, was the Irish National
Land League.
This brings us to September of 1880.
The leader of the Land League, Parliament
member Charles Stewart Parnell, was giving
a speech to many of the members of that organization.
During the speech, after the crowd, in true
mob-like fashion, expressed that any tenant
farmer who bids on an evicted neighbor’s
land should be killed, Parnell humbly suggested
that another tact should be used.
Rather than murder the individual, he proposed
it would be more Christian to simply “shun
him on the fair green and in the market place,
and even in the place of worship, by leaving
him alone, by putting him in moral Coventry,
by isolating him from the rest of the country,
as if he were the leper of old – you must
show him your detestation of the crime he
committed.”
Essentially, they were to be boycotted, but
they didn’t have that term yet, though they
wouldn’t have to wait long.
The first documented reference of “Boycott”
being used as a verb was just two weeks after
that speech.
At the time, Captain Charles Boycott, now
retired from the military, was working as
a land manager for the third Earl of Erne,
John Crichton.
The harvest that year wasn’t turning out
well for many farmers, so as a concession
to tenants, Boycott decided to reduce their
rent by 10%.
Rather than accept this, his tenants demanded
a 25% reduction, which Boycott’s boss, the
Earl of Erne, refused.
In the end, 11 of the Earl’s tenants didn’t
pay their rent.
Thus, a mere three days after this speech,
Boycott began the process of serving eviction
notices to those who hadn’t paid, sending
out the Constabulary to do this.
Needless to say, this did not go over well
with the already riled up masses.
Upon the tenants realizing eviction notices
were going out, the women of the area began
throwing things such as rocks and manure at
those delivering the notices until the Constabulary
left without being able to serve all the notices
to the head of the households, which was required
by law for the eviction notice to be considered
served.
Without the notices delivered, nobody had
to leave their homes.
Next, the teaming masses decided to use Parnell’s
proposed social ostracism against Boycott
and anyone who worked under him.
Soon, those who worked under Boycott began
leaving his service, often with those workers
being coerced and threatened by others until
they, too, joined in the ostracizing of Boycott.
This ultimately left Boycott with a large
estate to manage, but no workers to farm the
remainder of the crops.
Other businesses also stopped being willing
to do business with Boycott; he couldn’t
even buy food locally and getting it from
afar was difficult as carriage drivers, ship
captains, and letter handlers on the whole
wouldn’t work with him.
In late November, this led to Boycott being
forced to leave his home, fleeing to Dublin.
Even there, he was met with hostility and
businesses that were willing to serve him
were threatened with being “boycotted.”
The practice of boycotting spread, and within
a decade whenever a business did something
to the dislike of the Irish National Land
League, the business would quickly find themself
boycotted, with the name for the practice
sticking due to the wide publication of Boycott’s
plight in the news.
By 1888, just eight years after Boycott was
first boycotted, the word even made it into
the New English Dictionary on Historical Principles,
better known today as the Oxford English Dictionary.
The word spread to other European languages
and quickly made it over to America when Captain
Boycott visited friends in Virginia, attempting
to do so in secret -registering under the
name “Charles Cunningham.”
The newspapers caught wind of his arrival
anyway and widely publicized his history,
which got the term firmly planted in American
English as well.
BONUS FACT
Boycott did get his crops harvested the year
he was boycotted, finding 50 workers from
out of town to come harvest his crops.
The problem was that the locals did not take
kindly to this, so the government had to step
in and had nearly one thousand soldiers escort
the workers and protect them while they worked.
Funny enough, this ended up costing the British
government about £10,000.
How much were the crops worth?
About £500.